il s'appelle sébastien enfants du
chaudron marmaille la couvre tout le
monde l'appelle
[Musique]
ce soir dans les locaux du kabardock au
port il a rendez vous avec les artistes
qu'ils partageront avec lui la scène du
festival sakifo
donc là on arrive dans la salle de
répétition nous présente l'équipe bâtie
futur alsa aux comores un âge qui n'y a
aucune base hors énergie du groupe plr
en attendant
comment alors j'ignore tout doucement
match et à tous où est le dernier venu
dans la bande
abdoun
au sakifo pour la première fois ils se
produiront tous ensemble elle utilise
histoire raconte à saint célestin bien
qu elle ait fait ce qu'il faut
[Musique]
l'ong
et c'est vrai que pour eux être invité
au sakifo est une reconnaissance c'est
la première fois distille que leur
musique musiques urbaines musiques des
quartiers est ainsi accueilli sur une
grande scène duceppe c'est pareil
williams pays opprimés par elle mais les
milieux belgique et celle de ce que nous
les aurons nous les fier de ça nous sort
qui nous les de la musique que nous fait
voilà quoi et nous nous aidera réunion
ne vais pas de la mairie
et voila quoi nous c'est la mafia des
milk et nous les frais de ce que nous
les de ce que j'ai fait
pour comprendre la recette du succès
nous avons rendez vous dans cet immeuble
du quartier du chaudron
ces sujets ou bonjour c'est madame ma
fille donc il a sonné à l'école comment
il fait d'être la compagne d'une star
locale grèce en défaut mais on s'habitue
et où son travail et syna graviers par
ford kent cabine propose les voir tous
les faits sur machine en fait en réalité
me guérit pas je donnais sur le mot
vraiment en fait nous a tout appris
alors elle me connaît pas les notes les
accords tout ça ban a par exemple sur le
projet d'un sont que
beaucoup mangé cette année sur le saut
de abdoul nous arrive et demos un mois
comme que les instrus pour moi c'est le
battement qui compte de plus comme la
clé voilà c'est comme ça
voilà comme l'acte il a dit dans la
centrale sains et tabac battement
mélanie arrive à tassette ces mecs là
grosse caisse n'a des cloches nancy
chien qui a while c'est comme djamel
avec stromae web et c'est exactement ça
faute rançon de deux chiens kabyle tue
moi je veux maintenant on voit jamais le
conifère sa vidéo li ziwei fossat faut
quand même un des animaux écrit
[Musique]
comme la bazoge après ben le plus
important de mes son bain la basse il
faut faire vibrer ouais enfin de mon
repère c'est ma pote comme moi que moi
du coup ma peau et citron
voilà être humain peut donc là je ne les
cherchez la vole donc et c'est ainsi que
se fabriquent des morceaux qui
collectionne les millions de vues sur
internet ça c'est le premier grand
succès grâce à laquelle c'est le le plus
gros seins c'est 11 millions de vues
faites le style défini de musique qu'il
nous fait maintenant on appelle ça la
gomme ans c'est de l'ambiance c'est
c'est de la fête comme dieu ben il gomme
et veut dire que ben allez puissance et
la glisse c'est un mélange de dance hall
de mon bâton de ramallah de reggaeton
ça nous prend un peu de tout et nous
fait un mélange est belle et à l'image
de la réunion peu après ben le deuxième
plus grand soin la manche et c'est
l'intérêt 110 millions de vues
10 millions de vues sur youtube ça
rapporte environ 10000 euros
résultat aujourd'hui sébastien vit de sa
musique et a pu arrêter son travail à la
mairie
donc tu rêves aurait imaginé un tel
succès non franchement et le prochain
succès de dj seb
ce sera peut-être ce nouveau morceau de
black tic il nous dévoile en exclusivité
[Musique]
en attendant sébastien continue à faire
danser la réunion dj résident d'une
boîte de nuit saint gilloise il mixe
plusieurs fois par semaine les succès
d'hier et ceux d'aujourd'hui les siens
avec toujours une certaine philosophie
[Musique]
là
c'est quoi le secret d'un bon dj abouti
g20 il fait plaisir les gens l'effectif
les gens étaient là fait voilà quoi nous
le la poudre du bonheur du plaisir aux
gens
donc c'est ça la recette dabo dj un c ur
de métier fait d'enfants ouais c'est mon
métier et j'ai un beau métier même
[Musique]
par les couleurs